Good morning John. Now you may have heard
that young women are insecure. And also young
men. And also old men and old women and kite
surfers and musicians and CEOs and you and
me and everyone deals with insecurity. But
there are a lot of young women here on YouTube
and also I think that they've been told
their entire lives to base their self-worth
on whether or not they are admired by men.
So there's an entire genre of video on YouTube
dedicated to the idea of telling women what
men like to see in them. So I figured, since
those videos do very well, I should hop on
the bandwagon myself and tell you what boys
look for in girls.
In Ethiopia's Karo tribe, women scar their
bellies as a form of sacred ceremonial tattoo
that is found to be very sexy. In the Kayan
tribe of Thailand, women use brass rings to
compress their chest and clavicle so that
their neck appears very long. The Mursi of
Ethiopia insert ceremonial plaques into their
lips to attract a man. In Japan, women have
their teeth cosmetically unstraightened because
crowded teeth is seen as endearing, while
a tribe in Indonesia thinks the height of
sexiness is pointy teeth, so they sharpen
their teeth with files. In 19th century Europe,
women wore garments that squeezed their waists
to tiny, tiny shapes while in Mauritania,
women send their daughters off to fat camps
to eat ten thousand calories a day because
there, stretch marks are seen as the height
of sexiness. Meanwhile in America, women appear
beautiful by painting their faces and shaving
their bodies. Likewise, different cultures
have different standards of beauty for men.
In England, they wear really tight pants for
example. And I wish I could pull those pants
off; I can't.
I have a point... several. But my main point
is that there is very little objectivity when
it comes to human mate selection. We're
crazy, we don't make any sense. And thus,
since whether or not someone wants to date
you is apparently based on complete randomness,
it's kind of a super terrible thing to base
your self-worth on. And this is regardless
of your gender, by the way. But I do think
that it's more of a problem for women. I
saw a post on Tumblr the other day; it was
wonderful. It said 'How do boys look so
hot and they never have to wear makeup?'
It was one on those moments where suddenly
you notice the water you've been swimming
in your whole life, right? Like we're always
surrounded by culture; we never notice it's
there; that's how culture works. But in
that moment, you're like 'Yeah! How come
boys don't have to wear makeup to look hot
and girls do?' 'Cause boys without makeup
don't look better than girls without makeup,
but in our culture they do, and I think that's
because we're pretty adamant about the fact
that women's value is based, not entirely
but significantly, on their beauty and that
a lot of their purpose is to be attractive
to men, which is messed up.
Of course, there's nothing wrong with wanting
to express yourself through your physical
appearance; everybody does that to some extent.
Makeup and fashion are supercool ways to express
yourself. We should express ourselves in all
of the ways that we can find to express ourselves
in - with our words and our actions and our
ideas and our clothes and our fingernails
and our haircuts. Don't let anybody rag
on you for expressing yourself however you
want to do it. And there's nothing wrong
with wanting to be appreciated for how you
look. I want to be appreciated for how I look,
but there is so much more to you that that.
There's so much more to life than that.
Girls are not the photons that hit the corneas
of boys. Regardless of your gender, regardless
of their gender, you do not exist to please
someone else. You exist for your own sake.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
(Music)
Did you ever wanna go
To back where we were before
Smell that pot smoke wafting out
From under your dad's door
And the steak knives by the bedside
Jokes cracked in the blacklight